in the past we've had need for authority
to make sure that you know people stay
in the lines and Bitcoin kind of encodes
that into the software itself so it's
not not much to say against something
that's a cheat proof on is too
transparent money system
I'm Amy Brock well for raisin TV and I
am here with Daniel and Nicolas morass
who have just created a film about
Bitcoin called the rise and rise of
Bitcoin and it's premiering today I
Tribeca Film Festival Bitcoin is the
most subversive technology on the planet
this is a system that is growing around
the entire world the government no
matter how many guns they draw cannot
change a mathematical problem I see the
democratization of technology is being a
really positive thing the pressure to
not screw up just gets bigger and bigger
you can basically put a bank in your
pocket it's pretty amazing
congratulations it's a wonderful film
I've watched it um what made you to
first get interested in Bitcoin in the
first place you two were brothers and
you've decided to make this film
together
what first interested you came across an
article and read about Bitcoin in 2011
early 2011 and I started looking into it
and it just got more and got more and
more interested in it and you know
started just following everything that
was going on reading the discussion
forums and eventually got involved in
Bitcoin mining and my brother was always
talking to him about it and he started
to get interested in it and yeah he just
he just kept telling me about Bitcoin
and at first I was like okay it's cool
but I've always looked up to my older
brother and you know the more you talked
about the more I naturally just became
intrigued by the subject matter and
after a while said hey this is really
cool and so we started talking about it
let's look Michael documentary and it
just slowly grew and grew and grew and
before you know we had a really chance
to make a much bigger film
well Bitcoin isn't exactly the most
visual thing but you guys did a great
job in this film what what did you find
were the biggest challenges in making a
film about Bitcoin one of the biggest
challenges I guess for me was that it
was it was really more of a journalistic
documentary just because we were
constantly chasing something that was
still happening it wasn't like we had
the story in front of us and then we
could go back and retell it it's still
telling itself so that was the biggest
challenge I think was knowing what
stories to cover what characters to go
after what was important why and what's
gonna stay relevant you know even from
it from a historical perspective and
then there's the challenge of just
finding a way to entertain the audience
and also explain what Bitcoin is along
the way do you think that people really
understand the full extent of the
technology and what it's capable of we
want to explain it to the point where
people go I get it and now I want to
learn more but if you go too deep into
it then I feel like you maybe lose
people and it becomes less of a film and
more of an informative piece what I
found interesting about the documentary
as I was watching it was a lot of the
key players in the film they actually by
the end of the film while currently have
been arrested or bankrupted do you think
this taints the idea of Bitcoin at all
don't actually because you know I I look
at Bitcoin as as a technology and
Bitcoin itself you know you shouldn't
any kind of morality attached to
necessarily I'm very much like you know
email or any other protocol that people
use and I think over time as people
learn more about it they kind of start
to see that bitcoin the technology is
completely separate from all the
externalities and how people are using
it and the film you know some of the
people have been involved in some
problems but others you know are looking
for a way to save money and make you
know I do better sales and their stores
or you know increase their you know
customer base and being that Bitcoin is
such a new technology we're just
beginning to see all the different
things that it can be used for it's only
natural that the people that were the
first ones to take the plunge and help
pave the way for Bitcoin are gonna run
into hurdles and hiccups like we look at
it as these were the people that went
out there and said hey I'm gonna take a
chance at something I'm gonna build a
startup but I'm gonna and it's it's
natural that you know you're gonna have
fallout you're gonna have people that
have to go through the tough stuff to
help pave the way for for big for the
bigger economy of Bitcoin there's very
much a regulatory atmosphere shrouding
Bitcoin at the moment there's a lot of
fear in the community and a lot of
people being pushed offshore because
they're just worried about the
regulatory environment especially in the
United States do you think that the
government actually has the ability to
kill Bitcoin in its infancy before it
really has a chance to take off it's
kind of hard to kill an idea and a
protocol I mean Bitcoin is some code and
it's out there and it's not something
that can be uninvented now you know it's
it's a new it's a solution to a problem
that a lot of computer scientists have
worked very hard trying to solve and
it's out there now and so you know I
think that there's a balance that you
know governments are are wary and
obviously are concerned with you know
legal use and you know consumer
protections and things like that but if
they you know are unto unfriendly to it
it's just going to move elsewhere
and even some of the characters in our
film have moved their businesses out of
the United States because the United
States is kind of not in the lead right
now now the tech industry just moves
it's such an incredible pace would you
consider that the Bitcoin protocol is
actually itself already outdated when
you have things like Bitcoin 2.0 and
aetherium in the works bitcoin is the
first mover advantage and it just has so
many people behind it already that
that's not going to change overnight
even if there's better system
that are being put in place right now
and people are experimenting it's just
that's the one that has all the momentum
and there's a lot of part people that
are a lot of people that are working
very hard to see that I can succeed you
know software can evolve software can
continue to be improved and if there's
competitors you know there's nothing to
prevent those you know new ideas from
being implemented in Bitcoin itself and
I like that there's a lot of competition
I think that you know those new market
solutions to those that think that types
of things tend to you know bubble up the
good ideas so I I actually like to see
that I like to see a lot of different
cryptocurrencies and because there's
it's opened a whole new you know realm
of ideas and all kinds of opportunities
for new software development one of the
interesting things about Bitcoin is that
no one really knows who created it and
you talked a little bit about the
mystery behind Satoshi Nakamoto Satoshi
she immediately went off the grid so
what do you think this says about the
character that is Satoshi Nakamoto does
this reveal anything about his identity
the type of person he is
obviously I think the one thing most
people can agree on is Satoshi valued
his privacy and he was very careful he
seems like Satoshi whether it's a person
or a group of people they he or they had
the foresight to see that hey this thing
really grows into a bigger system it
might be wise to kind of stay under the
radar and not be a public figure and and
I think it's a good thing I think it's
helped actually you know Bitcoin grow
because there's not one person you can
point to and say this guy created let's
talk to him and see why or her that
matter I think that Satoshi probably
just wanted to see the technology mature
more the amount of work is pretty
obvious that Satoshi had been working on
Bitcoin for a long time it's a lot of
thought was put into it and I think it's
natural for somebody to not want
negative attention for their project and
potentially be killed when it's still in
its infancy right and just to wrap up I
just want you to paint me a picture of
what the world will look like in ten
years time and where does Bitcoin fit
into that world
from the filmmaker perspective it is
going to change a lot of the way things
will function how long that will be I
have no idea but it's it's it's a force
and it's gonna be interesting to see how
it plays out if you look at it at its
core it's kind of hard to argue against
the technology that essentially prevents
cheating and prevents bad actors from
you know hurting it itself
and you know it it's not that it's you
know an anti Authority Authority kind of
thing it said it just makes certain
certain you know in the past we've had
need for authority to to make sure that
you know people stay in the lines and
Bitcoin kind of encodes that into the
software itself so there's not not much
to say against something that's a cheat
proof on is too transparent when you
system it's kind of you know target
argue against that as a bad thing
you